the state of emergency in New York City
New York had just surpassed 7 000 covet
cases the most cases in the state and 35
coveted related deaths this is
overwhelming the city's hospitals and
First Responders the virus was spreading
fast the number of cases doubling in the
New York City area overnight fear was
setting in the community spread Dynamic
is unpredictable and worrisome then
Governor Andrew Cuomo had seen enough
and did the unthinkable and ordered New
York to be shut down completely it was
March 20th 2020. today we're bringing it
to 100 percent of the workforce must
stay home and when I talk about the most
drastic action we can take this is the
most drastic action we can take
New York would soon become the global
epicenter of the covet outbreak three
years on and 6.5 million coveted cases
and more than 61 000 deaths later what
lessons have been learned this
silent pendant like associated with it
and those are the individuals that have
gotten infected with covid-19 are
suffering from long covet and even those
individuals that have recovered from
their initial infection and now are at
higher risk for cardiovascular and lung
damage and liver damage and kidney
damage but she also points to four other
lessons first The Strain on Hospital
staff and supplies second changing
people's behavior with social distancing
and mask wearing third how covet hit the
economically disadvantaged harder than
others and fourth how misinformation
affected the pandemic response there are
some positive lessons before the
pandemic it was widely believed it took
at least five to ten years to create a
new vaccine and then bring it to Market
but with the covid-19 vaccine it proved
that it can happen in a lot less time
it's kind of incredible to think about
just how rapidly we had functional
vaccines for the nation and that were
then able to contribute to Society New
York's current governor Kathy hokel last
month ended the mask mandate in
hospitals that had been in place for
nearly three years but her office still
sends out daily covered updates on
average around 10 people still die every
day in the state that was once the
epicenter Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New
York